in today's money watch we're focusing on
tax filing and what to do with your
refund Tuesday April 18th is the last
day to file for most Americans more than
80 million people have already filed and
more than 59 million have received their
refunds the average tax refund this year
is more than 11 lower than last year due
to the termination of covid-19 relief
measures CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here to talk about it all
Jill good to see you good to be here all
right so if you're like me it's less
than two weeks to go and you haven't
filed yet what should people be thinking
about where should they start number one
decision do I file with a standard
deduction or am I an itemizer standard
deduction it's a set amount it's
statutory meaning it's in the law and it
goes up every year with inflation I
itemizing means you add up a bunch of
different categories state and local
taxes mortgage interests charitable
donations if those total more than the
standard deduction amount then you're an
itemizer but that's pretty simple it's
just a list and a little bit of adding
and subtracting and you're saying people
focus on deductions but claiming tax
credits is the way to go oh my gosh the
tax credits are unbelievable that's a
dollar for dollar reduction in your tax
bill so some of the big ones that you've
heard of the Earned Income Tax Credit
aimed at people who are mid to low
earners the child tax credit I know it's
a little bit less than it was last year
but it's still very juicy there's a
dependent than child tax credit there's
a Savers credit there's a tax credit for
people who help pay their kids college
expenses these are vast numbers of
dollars that the IRS says people leave
on the table because they're not
claiming them so important to to really
know where you can claim what are some
ways though that people can use a refund
if they in fact are expecting a refund
so we know the average refund amount is
running at about twenty nine hundred
dollars and frankly gang I have to go
back to my boring old big three and
they're not boring but we have got to
get people to focus on using these
dollars to beef up their emergency
Reserve funds 6 to 12 months of your
living expenses you'll need that if
things slow down in the economy paying
off your high interest debt and then
hopefully funding retirement to the best
of your ability especially if you work
for a place that has a match so speaking
of retirement a lot of people use their
refunds to invest in their IRAs or their
Roth IRAs for the people who don't know
the difference what is the difference
when you look at a traditional
retirement account it means you're
getting a tax deduction today for the
money you put in that account later when
you take the money out at retirement at
maybe 59 and a half is the earliest but
the government forces you to take the
money out in your 70s that's when you
have to pay taxes at whatever the tax
rates are in the future a Roth you pay
pay the tax that's due today the money
gets invested when you take it out later
there's no tax due why is it so
important because the vast majority of
tax experts and economists believe tax
rates are probably going higher than
where they are today it's just the most
likely path what about the markets
because I mean they are very volatile
these days but if you were to recommend
areas to invest the most important thing
is to have a game plan if you've got the
time to be able to withstand the ups and
the Downs please a nice Diversified
portfolio some stock some bonds some
cash not all eggs in one basket flat I
know you're an adherence and I'm feeling
Natalie as well I do just be really
clear you're going to have some bad
times don't bail when things get hot yes
crypto Bros no I'm just kidding
ER always great advice thank you very
much coming up we're gonna have our top
of the table
[Laughter]
today's money watch is sponsored by
Edward Jones Life Is For Living let's
partner for all of it